hey let me ask you if uh Allan miles
came to me and you and said listen yes
we've got a Smallville movie I already
answered it well Smallville movie I mean
I'd be like yes let's hear it I don't
know how it would happen but they came
up with an idea for Smallville movie or
five years later or it was right before
like let's say they just said we have
this idea it's before you still be
before you come Superman and it's this
little window here it's this like and we
want make a movie and we've got this
great idea and it's going to be on
Netflix would you consider it of course
I mean listen I I was thinking about
this the other day um right before we
did our our our TF podcast but like no
we were on one of the most successful
shows in the history of Television like
top 50 from that show I've never got an
incoming call from anyone involved in
that show for further work and I don't
mean to I'm not saying that like I don't
feel bad about that I don't harp on
anybody about that but you would think
that when you're you're success
successful you would be continued
successful with successful people but I
think the time has changed I think it's
um if but with Alam miles reaching out
with anything of course I would consider
it I mean I think you and you and I
playing characters on uh
Wednesday probably not together but
separately as cameos or not cameos but
as characters it' be fun as hell dude if
they call yeah of course those people if
Bean was directing a pilot you know what
I mean like let's go Glen was directing
a pilot you're right you're right let me
go let's go back to that um it
is look it is sort of sad I think in
this world there are a few people who
they come up together they start making
things and they put all their friends in
it and they they constantly use their
friends there's very few people like
that um I've had many friends who have
become tremendous successes some put
their friends in the movies some don't
they're also under different influences
Studio casting let's give them that sure
but it's people
think it's hard enough getting a movie
from people that don't know you but when
you're not getting things from people
that do know you then it's like oh my
god well now I'm really [__] that's
true it's it's funny but uh but it's
cool that you would do a Smallville
movie I think that it'd be it it' be
hilarious the concept they'd be like Tom
I want you to get ripped I want you to
lose 20 lbs Rosen bomb I want you to do
this I want you to look this you're
shaving your head and we're we're doing
this and we're getting you know and
we're get and it'd be pretty fun I don't
know if is that more that sounds more
like Al Than Miles by the way yeah be
like no no no terrible idea terrible
idea